COMING DOWN TO THE END OF THIS
FIRST FOR
THE WARRIORS.
YOU'RE WATCHING THE NBA ON TNT.
FIFIRSRST T HAHALFLF. .
HAHAMPMPTOTON,N,  WIWITHTH  A A
HERE FOR THE RAAN PUSH BACK ABO
SMART THING,
YOU ARE SEEING THEM COME
ACTIVE.
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS GOING TO
TAKE A  PLAY BY RUSS,
DOUBLE-TEAMING, SH
AHEAD.
LeBRON IS LIKE, YEAH.
ntonio: Y
THERE.
>> Joel: OH, YEAH, I GOT
KELLY.
KELLY COULDN'T GO A LENNIX WAS N
THE GAME AND THEN DON'T EVER
-- THAT'S
AGAINST A DOUBLE.
>> Mark: FOURNIER GOES QUICK,
AND LOBS.
>> Mark: YOU CAN'T GIVE HIM
OFFENSE THE RI
IT'S A CHEMISTRY, WHETHER ON OR
OFF THE FLOOR.   A BUSINESS
DECISION, AND SOMETIMESOKONGWU.
HAYES.
RUN AND USE YOUR SPEED TO YOUR
ADVANTAGE.
VASSELL. JR. UP.
THE POWER OF THE DUNK RIGHT
MAN GETS THE FOUL ON CARTER.
.
SPINNING, REELING, DUNKSETUP, 3
GAME.ING IT
JOSE.
>> Craig: AND HE JUST BLOCKED A.
ALL RIGHT?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WEKING OFF
MIDDLE OF THE LANE.